lieber filmen kuban lieber alex meier
liebe freundinnen und freunde der jungen
union deutschlands
herzlichen dank für die so überaus
freundliche begrüßung
herzlichen dank dass wir uns heute abend
in saarbrücken sehen
herzlichen dank für die unterstützung
die ich im letzten jahr von vielen aus
der jungen union bekommen habe
[Applaus]
vielen dank für das engagierte
miteinander und vielen dank an alle die
im letzten jahr in hamburg aber auch auf
acht regionalkonferenzen zuvor
diese partei spannend gemacht haben
die christlich demokratische union hat
im letzten jahr gezeigt welches
ungeheure potenzial in dieser partei
steckt und es war völlig klar dass wir
nach dem siebten dezember nach diesem
parteitag diesem spannungsbogen nicht
unbegrenzt weiter aufrechterhalten
es war klar dass dann der alltag wieder
beginnt
und es war auch klar dass annegret kramp
karrenbauer als neue parteivorsitzende
ja auch fehler macht liebe freundinnen
und freunde ich hätte auch fehler
gemacht
andere vielleicht vielleicht sogar noch
schwerere ich hätte fehler gemacht jeder
andere in diesem amt auch aber das ist
kein grund doch doch
doch das ist
liebe freundinnen und freunde und
deswegen will ich es gleich zu beginn
sagen ja ich kann das verstehen
da sind wir die frage diskutiert wird
wie es weitergeht wie vielleicht weitere
personalentscheidungen zu treffen sind
unabhängig davon welches verfahren man
wählt wir haben im letzten jahr die
ganze partei an diesem verfahren
beteiligt wir hatten einen guten
parteitag in hamburg
und ich habe auch wirklich fester und
tiefer überzeugung angriff kam
karrenbauer zugesagt ihr bei dieser
schwierigen aufgabe die sie angenommen
hat am 17 dezember 2018 in hamburg zu
helfen und sie zu unterstützen und zu
dieser zusage stehe ich uneingeschränkt
ich stehe dazu
denn diese freunde
[Applaus]
diese diese partei wird in ihrer ganzen
breite und tiefe junge ältere sozial
engagierte liberale konservative diese
partei wird in ihrer ganzen breite in
deutschland gebraucht
und da müssen wir alle mithelfen und am
ende wird es irgendwann vielleicht zum
jahreswechsel anfang 2020 vielleicht
irgendwann ende 2020 spätestens ende 20
21 wird es in deutschland eine
bundestagswahl geben und bei dieser
bundestagswahl kommt es darauf an dass
die union mit spannenden inhaltlichen
aussagen mit einem überzeugenden team
sich der verantwortung den wählern
gegenüberstellt und um die mehrheit in
deutschland trinkt und dazu muss jeder
von uns an jedem platz beitragen in
deutschland
[Applaus]
liebe freunde danke dass die junge union
sich mit diesen themen beschäftigt die
schon ein bisschen das gefühl dafür
geben welche themen in den nächsten
jahren und jahrzehnten wichtig sein
werden
ich nehme aus den antrags beratungen die
sie morgen und übermorgen hier vornehmen
werden zwei heraus sie beschäftigen sich
intensiv mit dem thema der
rentenversicherung in diesen stunden
jetzt gerade bringt die kommission in
berlin um die frage wie man denn diese
so genannte grundrente umsetzen kann
die grundrente steht im
koalitionsvertrag aber im
koalitionsvertrag steht nicht nur die
grundrente sondern es steht im
koalitionsvertrag dass diese grundrente
mit einer bedürftigkeitsprüfung versehen
wird
und ich will carsten linnemann der hier
ist und der mittelstandsvereinigung
genauso wie der jungen union herzlich
danken herzlich danken dass diese beiden
wichtigen gruppierungen in der union
diese beiden wichtigen vereinigungen
klipp und klar sagen
bedürftigkeitsprüfung heißt
bedürftigkeitsprüfung und das muss auch
gemacht werden
schon die grundrente ist ein kompromiss
eigentlich ist die schon ein verstoß
gegen das beitragsfinanzierte
leistungsorientierte rentensystem in der
bundesrepublik deutschland eigentlich
ist das schon ein schritt zu weit
aber natürlich muss man in einer
koalition insbesondere mit den
sozialdemokraten anhalt kompromisse
machen
aber mehr geht nun wirklich nicht denn
wenn es mehr wird dann ist es keine
respekt rente dann ist es respektlos vor
allen beitragszahlern vor allen
zukünftigen rentnern und vor allem
völlig respektlos vor der jungen
generation in deutschland völlig
respektlos
[Applaus]
ich weiß ja auch wie das weitergeht denn
das kommt dann hat man die grundrente
also das grundeinkommen das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen für die
ältere generation
ich gebe ihnen brief und siegel darauf
wenige tage später wird die spd die
forderung erheben dasselbe was sie für
die älteren macht jetzt auch für die
ganz jungen zu machen dann wird man das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen für die
kinder machen müssen
wer will dagegen dann ernsthaft etwas
sagen wenn man für die älteren gemacht
hat wird man so für die kinder machen
müssen so und dann die sozialdemokraten
großartig sind in der erfindung von
gerechtigkeitslücken wird diese
entscheidung wird diese entscheidung
[Applaus]
ja ich liebe freunde ich will dieses
stichwort einmal aufnehmen mich erstaunt
das schon einigermaßen dieser
sozialstaat ist noch nie so gut aus
finanziert gewesen wie heute
wir haben noch nie so viel geld
ausgegeben für den sozialstaat die im
jahr 2009 10 ein drittel unseres
bruttoinlandsprodukt 52 prozent des
bundeshaushaltes gehen für den
sozialstaat bundesrepublik deutschland
und trotzdem wird die zahl der
gerechtigkeitslücken jeden tag und jede
woche größer was ist in diesem lande
eigentlich los
[Applaus]
ich sage ihnen
deswegen
dann nämlich wird die allergrößte
gerechtigkeitslücke entdeckt werden von
den sozialdemokraten das nämlich
zwischen den älteren und den kindern
irgendwo noch welche unterwegs sind also
diejenigen die keine kinder mehr sind
aber noch keine rentner
das ist dann die größte
gerechtigkeitslücke und die müssen auch
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
bekommen das ist sozialdemokratische
umverteilungspolitik das ist
sozialdemokratische politik so wie sie
gerne hätten am liebsten alle gleich und
keiner stellt mehr irgendeine frage so
und deswegen bitte auch hier gilt wehret
den anfängen stoppt den unfug bevor er
system wird und bevor er routine wird
die union muss klipp und klar junge
union die ganze union die wirtschafts-
und mittelstandsvereinigung alle und die
sozialausschüsse hoffentlich auch wir
müssen alle dafür eintreten dass es bei
diesem kompromiss bleibt eine grundrente
ja wenn sie denn nötig ist aber mit
strikter bedürftigkeitsprüfung sonst
kann sie die zustimmung der union im
deutschen bundestag nicht viel
[Applaus]
wie eine freundin freunde
liebe freundinnen und freunde
sie befassen sich mit einem zweiten
großen thema nämlich mit der
umweltpolitik mit der energiepolitik mit
der wirtschaftspolitik in unserem land
ich muss sagen
tilman kube an herzlichen dank auch an
dieser stelle für diesen engagierten
vortrag hier heute abend für dieses
engagierte wort eines jungen union
bundesvorsitzenden das war wirklich
klasse eine nachbarin da unten hat mir
gerade gesagt rampensau das war richtig
gut was tillmann kuba gebracht hat
[Applaus]
und deswegen erlaube ich mir zu diesem
thema noch einmal etwas zu sagen ja wir
müssen etwas tun und jetzt im ernst wir
haben mit dem klimawandel auf dieser
welt ein ernsthaftes ein großes ein
wirklich großes problem
und hier in diesem saal wird niemand
sitzen der das bestreitet dass wir ein
ernsthaftes großes problem haben mit dem
klimawandel
aber wenn wir dieses problem lösen
wollen wird dass deutschland alleine
nicht können
ich gebe ihnen zwei beispiele im jahr
2019 werden auf der welt 70 millionen
autos gebaut und 20 millionen lkws im
jahr 2030 werden nach allen prognosen
die es gibt auch noch 70 millionen pkws
und 20 millionen lkws gebaut
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr alle mit
verbrennungsmotoren viele mit
elektromotoren aber ganz gewiss auch
viele mit anderen alternativen
technologien
wenn wir bei diesen 90 millionen
fahrzeugen im jahr 2030 die gebaut
werden
ob deutschland das will oder nicht die
werden gebaut auf dieser welt wenn wir
bei diesen 90 millionen fahrzeugen noch
dabei sein wollen mit unserer
technologie
dann müssen wir heute technologie offen
sein für das was in der antriebstechnik
geschieht
[Applaus]
und dann dürfen wir uns nicht einseitig
zu einem zu frühen zeitpunkt auf eine
einzige technologie festlegen von der
niemand von uns weiß ob sie in zehn
jahren wirklich die einzige antwort auf
den verbrennungsmotor ist in diesem
zusammenhang will ich übrigens in diesem
zusammenhang will ich übrigens noch ein
sprachliches thema ansprechen liebe
freunde ganz deutschland spricht vom
diesel skandal
dieses wort diesel skandal ist von den
deutschen umweltverbänden in den
sprachgebrauch eingeführt worden
wir haben es alle mehr oder weniger
kritiklos übernommen
ich sage es gibt keinen diesel skandal
es gibt es gibt liebe freunde
es gibt einen betrugsskandal von teilen
der deutschen automobilindustrie an
diesem land an den verbrauchern am start
und seinen regeln aber das wort diesen
skandal diskreditiert eine technologie
die die modernste ist auf der ganzen
welt die aus deutschland kommt
[Applaus]
die aus deutschland kommt und die einen
nachhaltigen beitrag dazu leisten kann
dass wir in zukunft abgasärmere und
umweltverträglichere fahrzeuge auf der
ganzen welt haben übrigens bau ziehen ja
das will ich an dieser stelle auch sagen
eine der wichtigsten aufgaben die an
generalsekretär hat und die auch auf sie
zukommt wir müssen wieder in der lage
sein begriffe in der politischen debatte
in deutschland zu prägen
unter einem generalsekretär heiner
geißler liebe freunde unter einem
generalsekretär heiner geißler wäre es
nicht möglich gewesen dass uns die
politische konkurrenz in dieser art und
weise die politische rhetorik abnimmt
wir alle darauf hereinfallen und wir
damit einen völlig falschen weg
bestreiten der am ende des tages nicht
zu mehr sondern zu weniger umweltschutz
in deutschland führt
lassen sie mich ein lassen sie mich ein
zweites technologisches beispiel sagen
damit uns klar wird in welcher dimension
wir hier diskutieren müssen zu jeder
minute
in jeder stunde an jedem tag der woche
an 365 tagen im jahr in jeder minute
sind mindestens eine million menschen
auf dieser welt im flugzeug unterwegs
zu jeder minute tag und nacht mindestens
eine million menschen sitzen zu jeder
minute im flugzeug irgendwo auf dieser
welt im jahr 2019 im jahr 2030 werden
auch noch zu jeder minute mindestens
eine million er zwei millionen menschen
in einem flugzeug auf der welt unterwegs
sein
die frage ist also nicht ob wir die
strecke von nürnberg bis münchen oder
meinetwegen von frankfurt nach nürnberg
für den flugverkehr sperren und
natürlich sinnvollerweise dort mit der
bahn fahren
die entscheidende frage ist ob wir als
europäische union und als bundesrepublik
deutschland teilnehmen an einer
technologischen entwicklung die auch das
fliegen im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
und zwar in den nächsten zehn 20 30 40
jahren umweltverträglich macht und
leistungsfähig macht so dass auch
europäische industrie an dieser
entwicklung teilnehmen kann
das ist die entscheidende frage
[Applaus]
und deswegen freue ich mich deswegen
freue ich mich darüber dass die junge
union auch mit ihren anträgen uns allen
hier den blick ein bisschen öffnet und
dass wir wirklich eine große debatte
führen über diese themen und nicht nur
eine kleine ich will hinzufügen dass
mich das etwas beschwert hat in den
letzten jahren etwa in der
energiepolitik auch in der
flüchtlingspolitik die man so und so
beurteilen kann
ich habe eine meinung dazu aber ich
respektiere dass man eine andere meinung
dazu haben kann aber dass zu viele
entscheidungen der bundesrepublik
deutschland den letzten jahren
ausschließlich aus der nationalen sicht
heraus getroffen worden sind liebe
freunde wir sind das einzige land
wir sind dass wir sind das einzige land
auf der welt das gleichzeitig aus
steinkohle braunkohle und kernenergie
aussteigt das macht kein anderes land
der welt okay wir machen das aber wenn
wir jetzt aber wenn wir jetzt daran
gehen aber wenn wir jetzt daran gehen
die entsprechenden energiepolitischen
entscheidungen für die zukunft zu
treffen wenn wir jetzt daran gehen die
ökonomischen und ökologischen
entscheidungen zu treffen
wenn wir jetzt daran gehen für den co2
handel zertifikate oder neue abgaben
einzuführen dann muss das alles so
ausgeprägt sein dass unsere europäischen
nachbarn das nicht nur wissen und
verstehen sondern dass sie auch die
chance haben das mit uns mit zusammen zu
machen sonst wird daraus nichts
deutschland alleine kann das nicht
leisten
und das
das ist der grund für mich warum ich
ihnen sagen möchte wir dürfen uns von
keiner partei in deutschland den rang ab
nehmen lassen die führende europapartei
der bundesrepublik deutschland und der
europäischen union zu sein
das sind die grünen nicht die
sozialdemokraten nicht die linkspartei
nicht die afg schon mal gar nicht das
sind wir die christlich-demokratische
und christlich soziale union
[Applaus]
und auch hier bitte keine illusionen
keine illusion diese europäische union
steht wahrscheinlich vor den größten
herausforderungen im 21 jahrhundert die
sie jemals in ihrer geschichte seit
ihrer gründung erlebt hat wir stellen
mit ursula von der leyen jetzt zum
ersten mal seit walter hallstein wieder
die präsidentin den präsidenten der
europäischen kommission
da können wir darauf nicht mal ein
bisschen stolz sein dass das gelungen
ist und dass wir diese wichtige position
für deutschland einnehmen muss darüber
auch dann bei den sozialdemokraten so
darum gebettelt werden liebe freunde
darin steckt eine ungeheuer große chance
und die bundesrepublik deutschland hat
im zweiten halbjahr 2020 die europäische
ratspräsidentschaft und dann wird es um
grundsatzentscheidungen in dieser
europäischen union geben
und bitte auch da keine täuschung keine
illusion
wir stehen vor ganz anderen großen
herausforderungen es ist nicht das ende
der geschichte wie francis fukuyama
einmal vor 20 jahren oder 30 jahren
geschrieben hat wir haben ein neues
kapitel aufgeschlagen die
nachkriegsordnung ist zu ende wir sind
dabei langsam zu verstehen wie sich
diese ordnung im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert entwickelt aber da wird
nicht mehr g6 g7 g8 eine rolle spielen
g20 da wird die frage zu beantworten
sein ist es eine welt die aus de 2
besteht also aus amerika und china
oder ist es eine welt de 3 die aus
amerika china und uns den europäern
besteht sind wir bereit mitzumachen
in dieser welt jeder
[Applaus]
und auch da geht es auch da geht es um
mehr als nur um wirtschaftlichen erfolg
da würde wilhelm röpke sagen es geht um
fragen jenseits von angebot und
nachfrage
die offene frage des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts für uns für unsere offenen
liberalen und freiheitlichen
gesellschaften ist die sind wir auch in
diesem einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
weiter eine offene freiheitliche
liberale gesellschaft oder obsiegen die
im liberalen demokratien die autoritären
politischen systeme nimmt auch das uns
gefangen dass die demokratie immer
weiter eingeschränkt wird oder kämpfen
wir für unsere freiheit und für unsere
demokratie und ich will ihnen in diesem
zusammenhang ein zitat aus der zeitung
von heute vortragen dass mich sehr
bewegt hat uns sehr beeindruckt hat und
dass ich ab jetzt sofort häufiger
zitieren würde
mathias döpfner schreibt in der welt vom
heutigen tag wie er so sagt er brauchen
eine wirklich wehrhafte demokratie wenn
deutschland die herausforderung eines
alten nun aber neu aufflammenden
islamistischen linken und rechten
antisemitismus nicht meistert eines
islamistischen eines linken und rechten
antisemitismus nicht meistert hat es
seine geschichtliche bewährungsprobe
verspielt und er sagt weiter
[Applaus]
und er schreibt weiter und so ist es die
welt schaut auf uns und will wissen wie
freiheits fähig und wie menschlich wir
nach 1945 geworden sind ende des zitats
wie freiheitlich und wie menschlich wie
die zukunft unseres landes und dieser
europäischen union gestalten liebe
freundinnen und freunde
diese verantwortung liegt auf
deutschland und in deutschland liegt
diese verantwortung auf der christ nicht
demokratischen und christlich-sozialen
union niemand anders wird dieser
verantwortung so gerecht werden können
wie wir
[Applaus]
es ist zeit es ist zeit auch wieder
darauf hinzuweisen dass die freiheit in
unserem land bedroht ist und nicht mit
abschließend mit einem zitat von karl
popper der schon vor vielen jahren
einmal gesagt hat im namen der toleranz
sollten wir das recht beanspruchen die
intoleranz nicht zu tolerieren
genau das ist die botschaft unserer zeit
genau das ist die antwort genau das ist
die antwort liebe freundinnen und
freunde auf islamismus auf linken und
rechten terror das ist die antwort auf
die schreckliche tat dieser woche in
halle die nicht allein steht sondern die
eine stimmung wieder gibt die leider in
teilen unserer bevölkerung um sich
greift dagegen zu stehen dagegen auch
wirklich christlich demokratische
politik zu machen dagegen aufzustehen
das haben wir heute hier gemeinsam
gezeigt mit dem gang zur synagoge in
saarbrücken
aber das ist nur ein kleiner teil wir
werden die politische auseinandersetzung
mit wem auch immer um diese zentrale
frage in den nächsten jahren führen
müssen und wenn sie wollen dass ich
dabei bin dann bin ich dabei die junge
union hat es verdient dass wir uns alle
dafür wirklich nach kräften einsetzen
fertigen
[Applaus]